[Musique]
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 c'est les inviter chaque jour rendez
vous avec celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité dans les yvelines et pour
terminer cette semaine vous entrerez
mathieu von eschen représentant de la
cfdt à la poste la poste qui vient
d'annoncer la suspension de tous les
projets de réorganisation concernant la
branche courrier dans la tente des
négociations sur les conditions de
travail il veut toucher également
nouveau président du coc death qui
s'exprimera s'exprimera sur cette
antenne le connais ce qui c'est cet
organe consultatif de l'agglomération il
évoquera ses priorités quelques mois
après l'arrivée des nouvelles communes à
50 ans et puis françois chérèque et
directeur de la mission locale sur notre
bassin reviendra sur le lancement de la
garantie jeunes un outil
d'accompagnement intensifs pour
permettre au boudin dans l'insertion
dans à la vie professionnelle
la direction de la poste vient donc de
suspendre tous ses projets de
réorganisation des métiers du courrier
jusqu'à la mi décembre une décision qui
fait suite à une demande des syndicats
afin de poursuivre sereinement les
négociations sur les conditions de
travail des facteurs et de l'ours
encadrant le mal être des facteurs c'est
ce dont nous allons parler avec mathieu
von eschen bonsoir et son représentant
cfdt à la poste des yvelines cette
annonce du report de cette
réorganisation envisagée c'était attendu
notamment par votre syndicat un
soulagement j'imagine déjà tout à fait
oui c'est un soulagement après il ya
effectivement un report de toutes les
réorganisations les stops pour l'instant
après continueront par la suite
moi ce que je vois là dedans c'est que
surtout on arrive en période de fort
trafic notamment par rapport aux colis
et sur la période de noël donc c'est
très bien la réorganisation qui était
qui et tantes qui va se remettre en
place par la suite en tout cas qui est
opérée en ce moment consiste en quoi
concrètement qu'elles n'ont pas changé
il ya des réorganisations tous les deux
ans dans tous les centres courrier à la
poste et nous on a des problématiques
qui sont liées à l'emploi notamment on a
pas mal d'emplois vacants donc là
clairement nous ce qu'on demande c'est
qu'il y ait des remplacements
qu'ils soient faits sur tous les postes
vacants et les départs programmés on
attend également qui est des choses
concrètes qu'il soit faite sur les
moyens de remplacement parce qu'à
l'heure actuelle quand une tournée il ya
un facteur qui est absent sa tournée
partagés sur les autres collègues donc
on attend que ses moyens de remplacement
du fait qu'ils aient beaucoup
d'absentéisme à la poste il ya des
choses qui soient faites et également en
termes de carrière
et sur la carrière il faudrait revoir
notamment pour les encadrants
puisqu'aujourd'hui on a des encadrants
qui vont en tournée j'espère rebondir ce
sourire sur ce que vous venez de dire
pour que ce soit clair pour les
téléspectateurs il ya beaucoup
d'absentéisme à la poste pourquoi ce que
dit comme ça les chiffres en tout cas
sur l'année 2015 il y avait de mémoire 6
millions de jours d'absence ce qui est
énorme sur 224 1000 de postiers oui
beaucoup d'absentéisme après des
conditions qu'ils savent explique c'est
les conditions de travail qui l'exclût
pas forcément je vais pas dire que tout
est basé sur des conditions de travail
mais faut se poser des questions quand
on voit que ça augmente d'année en année
je pense que les conditions de travail
sont pour quelque chose il ya des
difficultés aussi à recruter ou en tout
cas à garder ensuite les salariés et qui
viennent travailler à la poste oui on a
une grosse difficulté effectivement à
recruter même sur les yvelines c'est le
cas et sur l'île de france de manière
générale
parce que le métier est difficile on est
dehors une bonne partie de la journée
avec les conditions climatiques
c'est un métier qui commence assez tôt
des facteurs se plaignent les débutants
de rentrer tard et les heures
supplémentaires ne sont pas compensés
donc pas payées quel est le salaire pour
un débutant en dix ans les 1200 euros on
est en émigrant smic parce que ça c'est
du niveau du smic aujourd'hui sept
difficultés que vous rencontrez enfin
vous nous dites que tous les deux ans il
ya des réorganisations ou que c'est pas
une nouveauté ces réorganisations
pourquoi il ya autant de réorganisation
c'est la normalité pour s'adapter aux
besoins déjà parce qu'il y ait une
baisse de trafic donc faut s'adapter à
cette baisse de traces des lieux
nouvelles technologies à l'envoi d'e
mails concrètement juste après le
courrier tout à fait donc il ya eu une
baisse de trafic donc à coude à côté de
ça la poste et de la productivité donc
ne remplace pas les départs voir et
supprime des jeunes des emplois si je
puis dire c'est effectivement tous les
départs qui ne sont pas remplacés
par contre on a une augmentation de nous
ce qu'on appelle les pays des petits
papiers un apport dans notamment due aux
commerces asiatiques on reçoit de plus
en plus avec internet de petits paquets
import donc et c'est pas pris en charge
dans le calcul des tourneurs donc ce qui
fait que vous avez autant de travail
voire un travail peut-être un peu plus
compliqué parce qu'il faut livrer des
colis il ya moins de monde pour
l'assurer exactement c'est ça
aujourd'hui qui pose qui pose problème
on parlait qu'en tout cas j'ai évoqué en
titre ce mal-être en utilisant ce mot de
mal être des facteurs il réel ce
mal-être aujourd'hui parce qu'ils aient
eu aussi et là aussi c'est une réalité
il ya eu plusieurs suicides aussi à la
poste pas spécifiquement dans les
yvelines mais au niveau au niveau
national le mal-être aujourd'hui est
toujours très présent oui oui il y en a
là les très mauvais un mal être il ya
une stratégie qui est pas forcément
comprise puisque lors de la stratégie et
l'organisation sur le terrain est
totalement différente donc là il ya une
cassure et
les facteurs eux mêmes les postiers de
manière générale ne comprennent pas
voilà donc
ça je pense que ça aura besoin
d'explications il ya un manque de
formation aussi où on assiste assez sur
la formation il faut un manque de bras
oui clairement le dialogue social
aujourd'hui il est possible oui il est
possible il ya une joie parce que la
direction a suspendu la réorganisation
oui oui il ya quand même il ya des
accords qui ont été signés dernièrement
même à la poste le dialogue social est
possible
j'en reviens sur vos revendications
aujourd'hui c'est d'embaucher
combler les postes qui manquent tout à
fait nous prévient salariés 20 facteurs
en tout cas sur la sur les i minutes sur
les yvelines ou sur les yvelines vous
demandez est-ce que les vins facteurs
mans porn soir grand bt et au delà de ça
on demande la cd isation actuel de
toutes les personnes qui seraient en cdd
ou en intérim parler des facteurs la
poste c'est aussi des centres de tri
c'est aussi des bureaux de poste tout
simplement est ce que la réalité pour
les employés des bureaux de poste des
centres de tri et la même est ce que là
aussi à des difficulté aujourd'hui ce
qui remet à l'être aussi il ya également
un mal-être dans les dents décembre de
trier au guichet il ya d'ailleurs des
négociations qui vont s'ouvrir dès le
mois de novembre sur ces deux branches
la merci d'être venu nous parler de
cette situation aujourd'hui à la poste
il ya vu cette mobilisation et puis hier
ces annonces donc de suspension à de la
réorganisation par la direction d'ici la
mi-décembre vous reviendra plateau et on
fera un point sur zone pour l'évolution
de cette situation merci à vous merci à
vous nous poursuivons ce 7,8 les invités
autre sujet le conseil de être
développement de saint quentin en
yvelines un nouveau président c'est un
entrepreneur du territoire yves fouchet
il aura pour mission de présider cet
organe consultatif ce code est ce qui
constitué d'acteurs de la vie locale qui
a pour but d'aider les élus de
l'agglomération dans leur réflexion sur
les grands projets du territoire ce rôle
est d'autant plus renforcée que
l'agglomération vous le savez s'est
agrandie avec cinq nouvelles villes
depuis le début de l'année écoutez donc
le nouveau président du coc des skis il
foucher au micro de nicolas kirillovitch
j'essaierai d'être de chef d'equipe
d'une équipe qui aura à traiter d'un
certain nombre de sujets et de grands
dossiers qui seront pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux
proposé par l'agglomération je pense
notamment aux grands projets de
territoire qui est un sujet majeur est
important et qui va sûrement nous
occuper un certain nombre de mois et
puis après le codis qui peut aussi
s'autosaisir je verrai avec des membres
du cos des skis que je découvre et
s'il y a des sujets importants à traiter
pour l'instant je n'ai pas de dax précis
ni arrêter le rôle encore une fois du
côté ce qui est d'abord d'être un outil
d'accompagnement des élus donc je pense
qu'il faut avancer avec
conviction mais aussi modestie et
attendre les sollicitations des élus
après on verra bien si ici ou là des
problématiques se posent sachant que moi
j'ai un horizon ou un tropisme
entrepreneuriale puisque je suis
entrepreneur à saint quentin depuis près
de 30 ans mais il y a aussi des membres
du tissu associatif il ya aussi des
personnalités qualifiées et enfin il ya
aussi des habitants donc je pense qu'il
va falloir qu'on semble numéro initions
dans un futur très proche pour voir si
au delà des sujets demandé par la
communauté d'agglo j'ai évoqué le projet
de territoire mais il ya aussi des
aspects de logements et puis un plan
d'habitat également qu'ils seront des
sujets à traiter s'il ya d'autres sujets
plus spécifiquement intéressant pour les
habitants ou pour le monde associatif
mon activité professionnelle
saint-quentinoise depuis longtemps va
bien entendu me servir puisque à des
sujets importants autour de l'habitat de
nos collaborateurs autour des transports
des collaborateurs et et puis parce que
saint quentin en yvelines la chance
d'être un territoire riche où il ya à
peu près autant d'emplois que
d'habitants mais j'ai aussi vécu 22 ans
à saint quentin donc j'en connais tous
les immenses avantages j'en connais
peut-être quelques petites faiblesses
mais au fond très très peu donc on verra
ensemble comment tout ça doit
fonctionner à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
toujours la mission locale présenté la
semaine passée son nouveau dispositif
pour aider les plus jeunes à trouver un
emploi la garantie celle ci profite
depuis le début du mois d'octobre une
quinzaine de personnes sur
l'agglomération accompagnement intensif
visites d'entreprises ateliers
thématiques doivent permettre au bout
d'un an maximum l'insertion dans la vie
professionnelle écouté le directeur de
la mission locale nous en dire plus
l'objectif de la garantie jeunes c'est
d'accompagner les jeunes vers
l'autonomie professionnelle et sociale
ça veut dire que durant tout le temps de
ses accompagnements qui va durer un an
on va travailler avec les jeunes bien
sûr leur accès à l'entreprise mais aussi
toutes les questions qui vont se poser à
eux dans le cadre de leur vie de jeune
adulte c'est à dire la question de
l'accès au logement 2
de la prévention en termes de santé par
exemple de la gestion du budget de
l'accès au droit des démarches
administratives faire sa première
déclaration d'impôts donc ça commence
par quatre semaines de deux formations
cinq jours sur sept à la mission locale
accompagnés par deux référentes garantie
jeunes alors elles vont bien sûr les
jeunes vont bien sûr très travaillé leur
projet professionnel et les démarches
vis-à-vis des entreprises que ça soit
pour rechercher des stages que ce soit
pour rechercher de l'intérim ou si
possible des contrats longue durée qui
est bien sûr leur demander qui est notre
objectif mais on va aussi travailler
durant ses quatre premières semaines
avec un certain nombre de partenaires du
territoire plutôt sur le champ social en
sachant aussi que des partenaires tels
que le club fasse vont intervenir sur
champ professionnel en organisant des
visites d'entreprises en nous en
travaillant avec les jeunes le cv la
lettre de motivation et après
le reste on l'accompagné mans va se
poursuivre de façon un peu moins
intensive puisqu'ils seront pas en
présentiel dans nos locaux tous les
jours mais par contre avec les
référentes garantie jeunes vivent les
jeunes vont avoir des démarches à
effectuer et nous ferons un retour très
régulier des démarches qu'ils effectuent
alors afin de sécuriser la disponibilité
des jeunes pour s'engager dans
dispositif
le jeune bénéficier du versement d'une
allocation égale ou rsa soit environ 470
euros ce versement d'allocations est
vraiment strictement soumis aux à un
investissement à une présence et un
investissement forts et un suivi des
démarches qui c'est qui est recommandée
c'est à dire qu'il ya des périodes de
flottement du jeune et bien la location
ce pourra être suspendu ou révisées à la
baisse
c'était un minimum 40 une sorte de
minimum garanti c'est 470 euros pour les
jeunes qui sont en situation d'emploi
suivant les ressources qu'ils vont tirer
de leur emploi ils pourront percevoir
tout ou partie de ces 470 euros
c'est la fin du set 8 les invités pour
aujourd'hui replay sur notre site
internet tv fil 78 points comme nouvelle
édition lundi 18h45 en attendant les
programmes se poursuivent bonne soirée
[Musique]